what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends
that was a horrible intro hello
everybody and welcome
back to unwax with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone
you guys you gotta watch the video
version of this podcast because sophia
has a heart what looks like a heart
drawn on her face
it is a heart and it looks like a heart
so i have a bowl there and i just
decided
so what was what was it what was the
inspiration behind your cosplay today
okay well yes i have been watching a lot
of anime
but also i don't know if you've ever
heard this song
how to be a heartbreaker by mariana in
the diamonds oh
i get it you're a heartbreaker then
sure yes i am a heartbreaker that's why
i have to
zone in on it but she has such a look
and every time like
since he knows this growing up all i
wanted to be was a pop star
that's true were you listening
um i was listening i swear
wait scarlett wanted to be fit here
skater
you you wanted to be oh this is really
bad
i actually feel bad you really don't
know
no give me a second give me a second
three two one
detective never once
in my life have i ever said i wanted to
be a detective
that is just what was it what was it
wait wait bake i wasn't saying baker
i told you i hate you so much
what was it a dj
oh yeah yeah sofia and i wanted to be
the duo don't you remember
like i was gonna be the dj and you were
gonna be the pop star
and now i guess that'll never happen
because sophia would be a terrible
partner to work with
i would just forget what you wanted to
be when you grow up i feel like you
could be a dj if you like still want it
to be
if anyone could maybe sistine could but
i also don't want to say
that anyone could be a dj because i now
know it's a lot harder
so random that we're on this topic right
now because i actually downloaded
soundcloud
like an hour ago you've done soundcloud
before this
no i did but i didn't have one remember
it was really big in high school and all
we would do is just like all the remix
songs and
we thought we were so cool for finding
like migos fight night before it like
came out
oh my god it was just like oh my god
trippy turtle we're like
no one knows him i'm back on it i'm back
on it are you dying how great it is
get ready for my next dj set soon i'd
love to see it
um okay so i feel like we have lots of
updates we say that every time but
before we get into the show
make sure if you haven't already follow
us on all of our platforms we post all
the video
content of this uh podcast on our
youtube channel
you know follow us on apple podcast
spotify
instagram unwaxed podcast
and if you want your questions to be
answered for our unsolicited advice
segment
make sure you go to the apple podcast
page go to unwaxed podcast
write your question in the ratings and
review section
and we will answer it and that is the
only way we're going to answer it
and then five stars not four
five five okay thank you we really
appreciate it we do
we do we need those and we love seeing
your questions
update yes christina and i
we are fickle people we like to change
our minds
we do we do we we go one place to
another
we if you haven't already if you haven't
already gotten that from the show
every single week we say we have a new
obsession last week i think was jersey
shore i mean
we're always changing our mind always a
few weeks
a few weeks ago a few months ago in the
beginning of shooting the show
we were sort of dabbling with the idea
with you guys saying you know what we're
gonna move out
we're gonna give you guys play-by-play
updates and we haven't done any of that
no but we have an update we have an
update
take it away girl we want to move
to miami drink all day
play
yeah i know you're probably like what
the frick why would you go to miami
you guys were planning on living in la
you guys were going to get some
new girl like apartment live with the
two of you maybe your cousin
but guess what people things change
corona hit and now sistine and i are
here
with our parents and we're like this
place is awesome
we kind of love this idea
i realized i'm an east coast gal
you realize you're an east coast girl
since when how did you know
i just love florida i really do i don't
know why i didn't expect to be so happy
here
i just love the people the weather i
don't know i love everything about it
and our parents
actually used to live in miami for how
many years did they live there
quite a while but i was born in miami um
we moved
pretty quickly after i was born to l.a
so i didn't get to spend that much
summer but
my roots are here so it just feels like
motherland
so we're kind of just dabbling with the
idea we're putting our toes in the water
if you will
and you know what why not
why freaking not i'll tell you why we
love miami though because yes our
parents are here
the weather is awesome i know in the
summer it can get really hot
and that's not great but so far every
time we've gone out and we've socialized
and we've really gone to get more of a
feel of this place yeah
the energy is so much different from la
the music is so different the
restaurants the weather it's like
i just feel like i'm at that age and
obviously you're at that age too where
in your early 20s everyone that is much
older always says
do the things you want to do now get it
out of your system because for the rest
of your life you're going to
you know maybe i'm just speaking to some
some very pessimistic people
but they're saying the rest of your life
you could be an adult and and you won't
get to travel as much especially when
you get a family and settle down
everything changes
so right now is when you're supposed to
take the opportunities to do those
things and explore and
have fun and i don't know i'm kind of
like at a yolo
kind of phase of my life let's just go
for it
if we hate it we leave we leave
i'm there forever it's there's no
commitment i mean right now our mom and
dad are here
we could go to l.a we have family there
too so if we want to
up and change i think that's also now a
time for change so
if you're listening if there is
something you are really wanting to do
there's a place you want to go i mean
coveted restrictions
i know but start to plan for it get
really excited about it
have some new perspective because i
really think since coming here
cysteine and i i wouldn't say are the
same people as we were in l.a day-to-day
we're definitely
much more confident we're much more
happy and you really can see a
difference in
us and i think in general when someone
is happier
you know true so that's my life
all right we got another update for
y'all do you remember
when we had chris medina the psychic
on our pot what episode was that oh did
i go check
i'll go check you keep talking we had
chris medina
come on our show he was a psychic and he
gave sophia a reading off air and they
gave me
pretty much a live reading on the show
and
we shot this maybe september october
and he was predicting things that were
going to happen in
february march of 2021 so we shot this
in november and it was episode 13. okay
so we had a few months to go until we
could actually see if these predictions
came true
and at the time sophie and i were
sitting there saying
oh that's not gonna happen the way my
life is right now it's probably going to
be the same in a few months
it happened it happened
it freaking happened you guys freaking
happened
and um we're a little shocked
a little shocked to say the least but no
um what else he said
was about the podcast how we
are going to probably be moving forward
to bigger and better things
pretty soon and we were like you know we
hope so
obviously we hope so right we have a
podcast and we want to go
global and he said that we haven't met
the main characters of our life that are
really going to pivot our career big
time and guess what guys
we made it we did and we can't say
anything now
but just you wait bet your bottom dollar
did you just see
my hand i look like a child um
no it's huge and we're so excited about
it and you know what it's been
a lot of work um cesina has been working
our asses off
and we just hope it comes through i
never want to jinx anything just like we
said before
but you know it'll be really really
really really freaking amazing i know
and i'm sorry we're being so vague right
now but just just wait a few weeks just
just let this
give you this all the beans if you like
seeing us now you'll see a lot more of
us
that was a big hint not really that was
a big hit
and if you don't like seeing us then you
can
just sorry learn something
speaking of um love and lust and all
that stuff
system she has been reading
erotica everyone what okay what i have
erotica sistine
i do too okay you know what
sophia bought me a kindle you guys and
i like to read i just haven't exactly
found
my topic that i like except for murder
mysteries and horror and
blood but i can't sleep when i read that
stuff
especially when i read non-fiction so
you know
one night i was just scrolling through
the bookstore and
i came across some erotica novels and i
thought they looked so funny because you
know what i mean it's like the very
the the cheesy guy yeah yeah and the guy
with the girl laying on the rock or like
right he's like wearing a tie with no
shirt and she's like pulling the tie
like just extreme cheese and i was like
i'm here for a good laugh
right and i started reading one i was
laughing i thought this is kind of
stupid
so i asked sophia and i said do you have
any recommendations and you know i said
absolutely i'm your older sister of
course i have some recommendations
i have the straight to the point i got
the warm slow burn romance i got the 50
shades of gray so
i gave cysteine what i thought was a
good
warm-up but good book because it is
probably one of the most popular ones
out of the group and i looked on
goodreads just to make sure
and i thought it would not be a hit for
you when i tell you guys
slow burn slow [ __ ] burn
sophia this book is called wallbanger
right so you would imagine it's like wow
we're banging some walls you know what i
mean
it's gonna be off the charts so i start
reading
one chapter five chapters in 10
15 20 chapters in
they haven't had sex
okay i'm gonna just put my point out
there
sistine likes now i know because i liked
the book she likes
straight to the point sex banging walls
left and right me
i think it's good to have some character
development build some plot up who are
the people
what's the scenario why are they having
sex where do they meet
sophia let me give the listeners even
more context
this book is so not romantic
at all that she starts crying
the main character starts crying when
she doesn't orgasm
what am i reading right now why why why
it doesn't matter what what
i don't remember that part it's better
it gets even better
finally at chapter 22 it happens
22. i don't even know why i hung in so
long but i was just
waiting i was like you know why i'm like
mad at this book i wanted to push
through
did you like the guy is he a cool
character like he kind of
i didn't like anything about it but i
was committed i was committed i just
remembered something about that book
that
you have mentioned to me the point of
view
at the end of the book so just when you
guys think it couldn't get worse for me
and if you really want like a cheese
ball book please read this book
and dm me and let me know what you think
or dm me if you have any suggestions
thank you very much
so i'm just about at my wit's end with
this book
but i know i'm almost done i'm a few
pages left i go okay let me just finish
it
there has to be a banging ending you
know
no pun intended that was a good one
thank you
thank you and all of a sudden i'm
reading it and it's
it's italicized you could tell it's from
a different perspective
the last five pages are from the cats
the cat's point of view so the main
character's
cat is watching the sex and is giving
me the point of view and i did you one
better
i brought the book here and i'm gonna
show you guys oh
no just so you guys understand
how crazy this is okay
this is from the book from the cat
they had finally quieted down after
several rounds
the feeder was sleeping soundly no the
feeder was not sleeping soundly
the feeder wait wait the feeder is the
owner the owner
okay the feeder was not sleeping soundly
without enough sleep she would be
unlikely to play with me
the following evening so this situation
would have to be remedied
she did seem to enjoy our games so i
would take matters into my own paws
jumping from the floor
i navigated my ways through his knees
legs arms and elbows seems like the
cat's getting involved
until i reached the pinnacle and came to
rest just beneath his chin
stretching out one pie placed it over
his breathing holes
stopped the nose noise momentarily
the tall one brushed away my effort and
then and then it goes on to say like the
point of view
like oh it's quite loud maybe i'll play
with my yarn ball in the corner
and this is what am i reading and then
ending with the cat's point of view so
thank you sophia
you're welcome thank you for that so
we're gonna just jump into our new topic
and it is called
story time what is story time ciste and
i have so many stories
so many they go from being dark
to hilarious and these are ones that
we've told our close friends and family
and we want to now tell you
and what better way than create a
segment called story time
and so i thought i would pop it off
and start with a pretty serious story
that is kind of crazy and really hard to
believe unless you were there
um so she can add some commentary in
there because she was
there for him let me tell you guys there
are this story
has never been shared with the world so
everything that we bring in every week
is going to be stuff that
has never been shared brand new content
only can find it on unwaxed so sophia
tell the story it is a good one this is
called
the stalker so
you guys are probably not surprised by
the fact that
we have had some stalkers yes they're
usually very creepy
and they're usually very persistent but
eventually
they go away some of them most of them
honestly we'll have a ton of dms
and they'll just disappear if we don't
answer sometimes we'll just block them
and it's good my first major soccer
started when i was just joining facebook
and i think i was around
13 14. i i'm guessing and
i didn't have that many friends on it
and this one guy from italy
his name is gabriel um i don't know if i
should say his name
yeah don't no okay
so it started out when i first got
facebook and i was around like
13 years old and i won't say his real
name but i'll just call him
the man that's not forever the man
stalker
the stalker we'll call him soccer right
stop the man whatever he's not the man
um and the messages were just rolling
in and it was very much like i'm in love
with you you're beautiful you're this
you're this and
it's kind of getting creepy and i keep
deleting it and keep coming back
and i might block him you create another
account and so it just was this ongoing
game that he was playing and it really
freaked
it really freaked you out it freaked me
out because i was so young
i was so young and i didn't really know
what a stalker like true like a real
stalker truly was
and so what were some of the examples of
of the messages that he would send you
well this is i'll explain because this
is the thing when i was
first on facebook to like when i was
starting to get older the messages just
got
even more intense and sexual and
um scary it started out with a lot of
like you're beautiful
um i want you you are everything to me
you're my life
and then it started to become i want to
marry you you are going to be my wife
um and then start getting into things
like i will kidnap you i will take you
um and we are going to make love and
then it starts getting
really really so obviously sophia would
tell this to our parents and talk about
it with the family and
we would always just say you know it's
scary and we keep blocking him and
and do not respond because you're giving
him what he wants
and there's no way he could ever
hurt you or find you because he's
halfway across the world
right so we didn't think anything of it
but it was very funny because
this one guy like we've got a lot of
those type of messages
but this one guy i don't know why did
not sit well with me and he was always
the one person
and by the way this continued even when
i got an instagram
any social media platform till i was
basically in college he'd always find a
way and so
the creepiest part was was this one
photo that he's used and it was always
just like the most
triggering scary thing and the even
worse
sistine actually was part of it because
he
took her number i don't know how he
found your number do you remember that
on vacation
yes i didn't even remember that he
somehow found my number
it's probably because i use a lot of
strange bootleg
websites and i plug all my information
in and
um he called me over 250 times
in an hour and i had to get a new number
i mean this guy
is insane so
what age you know i would say cut to
say a year yeah of high school i was 18.
um and the messages just stopped
gone i was like weird okay
i'm like thank goodness like i don't
want it to keep coming
um and so i just like continued
throughout my day i was like maybe he's
just over it
he's like given up and then i get into
college and it is my first week of
school
and you guys when you're a college kid
it's your first week of school do you
know how hectic it is
you are especially at where i went to
usc
the first week is sorority rushing which
is like seven days
you're moving into your apartment you
are trying to figure out your class
schedule
and i was just super overwhelmed with
everything but i wasn't even really
thinking about anything else right
so one day i'm in my calculus class
what day was this specifically my
birthday
my birthday is the first birthday
okay so my birthday um first week of
school i'm in my calculus class i'm
looking at this teacher that has no
shoes on he's french and he's
using commas as decimals and decimals as
comments so i in your name i was
probably going to drop the class because
i'm not good at math i'm like
um and these three cops come in
fully in gear they're not campus place
they're like me
they're cops and
they pull my teacher out and i make a
joke with my friends and
i mean my friends were making jokes like
oh maybe he's getting into trouble for
like doing something and we're just
trying to create scenarios laughing
and one of my guys friends was like oh
what if it's for you and i go
yeah right they come back in and they go
is sophia stallone in this room and i
get up and i start following them out
the door
can i just can i just introduce for a
second i want you guys to imagine it's
your first week of school
it's your birthday you're just making
new friends you're in an
auditorium a classroom full of kids
and three cops pull you out
just think about that yeah and i was
trying to thank you
is this a magic mic show is
your birthday
so they pull me out of the room and i'm
trying to think of every single scenario
that i have done in the last two days on
campus
you're like i missed the class i wore
the wrong color
shorts for rushing maybe someone in my
room planted something
i'm just like thinking like did i like
did i steal something like no i don't
steal did i
did it hurt someone's feeling like i
haven't even talked to anybody heard
someone's feeling
i i just a hundred things and i'm
shaking at this point
and they say can i see your id i show
them
and then they go do you know this man
and they show me a photo it's a photo of
um it's like it's kind of a blurry photo
he used it on his phone and it's a guy
sitting in a room
it looks kind of like a very padded
white one table type of almost what is
it called
like a holding room a holding room
interrogation room
sort of yeah exactly and
the photo is of the stalker
and i have not seen since i was 14 years
old
any other photo other than the one where
he's been harassing me online for all
those years
and then i thought he was out of my life
and so i literally
break down crying and i'm shaking and i
cannot breathe and even right now
talking about it is making me laugh
it gave you so much anxiety growing up
so many sleepless nights
we did our best to convince you that
this wouldn't happen that this man would
never come
back into your life and the fact that he
did i mean it's so triggering it's so
triggering okay so what happened there
so i go
well how do you have this photo and he
goes
he is here on campus
but but before
we say anything further we really need
you to come to the station
so i am by the way what i'm wearing i'm
wearing a birthday sash
i am walking around i'm freaking out i'm
taking everything off i'm like i can't
even focus on this
and i go to the police station i'm there
for like six
hours and they tell me basically that
the night before he got onto campus
and he was trying to get into the
building of our dorm
and thankfully there's a lot of access
codes you have to get into but
he didn't even really make it past the
first one so he left don't know where
he walked onto campus around 12 o'clock
at night so i'm not sure
how he got it then he was probably
wandering
and then he came back that day and
he was asking all of these kids and
these um
like teachers where i was like what
classroom i was in
um and so long story short
one of the campus police was like this
is kind of creepy this guy doesn't look
like he's supposed to be here
let me take him in and the lowdown was
was that he's been say he lives with his
mom
in another country and he's been saving
up all this money
so he can fly out to surprise me for my
birthday because
apparently a person that was pretending
to be me online
was telling him when he was responding
to things like
or saying things like i want to marry
you take me away my fake accounts
thanks a lot if any of you guys do that
thanks a lot guys um just saying
please come get me help me i need you i
need you
i'm not even getting to the sexual part
all this stuff but it was graphic
it was graphic and so
when we're walking when we were walking
into the police station this is one of
the freakiest parts
that guys the police officer said please
don't stand near the window we don't
want him to see you because
he's very very highly triggered or
sensitive
and he kind of saw me and when i say
it was feral the way he reacted like
like he was breathing so quickly his
eyes got wide
and he was so excited it was it was so
it was not a normal excitement it was
disturbing it was like you could tell
that this is not a serial killer look
it was a creepy creepy friggin look like
that was not excitement because
it was my birthday and he just wanted to
say hey happy birthday no
no it was very much a i
have been dreaming about you for 15
years
typed in 10 years this happens sophia is
freaking out they're holding her in
another room
they start to call my mom my dad
me scarlet we all get pulled out of
school and
i am hysterical at this point because i
don't know all the details someone just
told me
very vaguely what happened and i thought
he had found you so you can imagine
my terror yeah and and you can imagine
what my parents were feeling
they were because let me tell you
protective doesn't even begin
to describe not even scratching the
surface
so they lost their marbles
yeah when this happened they lost it
enough happening to the guy
well so after having to sit for
another two hours going through all of
the messages
all over again and the screenshots to
prove that this guy has been stalking me
and like kind of having to rehash all
those old memories
um uh he was taken away
he went to jail for a night and they
couldn't really hold him but
they i think somehow got him on a flight
back to his country
to get him out of there because he
wasn't supposed to even be there it was
like
he had all these other things against
him and i don't know you know
it's being in the public eye i think for
both of us
it it can be very fun but it can be very
scary
and i still today have nightmares about
it and it's really scary when you have
these guys that are creepy online
messaging you these things so
if you're one of those guys honestly if
you're like
don't do that like i'm not going to
answer you it's just dumb don't do it to
young girls it's
very creepy we're not interested you
know who you are
um yeah so i mean
yeah happy birthday sophia it was a
great birthday
so laurel the story is please don't
stalk me
that was our first story time segment i
feel like it was a bit
dark and intense but the next week i'm
bringing one in and you can
bet your ass it'll probably be
just as crazy
oh ladies and gentlemen we have a knock
at the door
who is it oh it's mister
oh welcome oh wow hello dad
west here thanks for coming on you gotta
come close to my speaker
but can we just talk about i'm gonna be
fashion police right now
what the hell are you wearing obnoxious
golf clothing you look like a fashion
peaky blinder
let me tell you guys if you if you can't
see the video right now he's wearing
salmon colored pants he's wearing a
royal blue shirt he's wearing a navy
blue
peaky blinders cap which and he's got
some dark purple
shoes on who dressed here
thank you for making a quick appearance
on the podcast we really appreciate
it this is your first appearance and
won't be your last
no i certainly won't because i plan on
sticking around
a lot okay so i know you guys have
missed this a lot
but we're back i've brought in a
conspiracy theory
christine is doing it today what do you
have for us esteem
i have brought in a theory you know the
lizard people conspiracy theory if you
guys haven't listened you gotta go back
and watch that sister sister episode
part one
everyone loved that one so i thought all
right let me try to be a little bit more
on brand with that
with something that really will bring
you back to childhood
something that everyone has seen and i'm
really going to blow your minds a bit i
might offend some
some fans of the show but that's what we
do here
what we do we're on wax all right so
this is the theory i brought in
the spongebob squarepants drug
conspiracy
theory what oh yeah
oh chocolate
no everybody you ever think that you
ever think
that spongebob and drugs would be in the
same sentence no but i'm about to blow
your mind
all right how do you do that
oh my god go ahead
all right so this is the theory
obviously i got out and read it so you
know it's
fact so this is the theory spongebob
squarepants is all about
drugs all right so they say
spongebob is on methamphetamines because
he's always really really happy
and energetic and occasionally paranoid
and if he's ever in a bad mood
it's the result of a major crash so he
goes from being really happy
to really sad or really angry there's no
middle ground
not done i'm not done patrick starr is a
stoner
he laughs at stupid things and he eats
all the time to be honest
don't disagree he must go through like a
pound of
weed a week wait actually i have a
question now we have to tell me
how do you make underground like
underwater weed
what type maybe it's not weed i also
have another theory associated with
their town bikini bottom that i think
it's um the result of muscular
nuclear uh testing theory it's just hold
on we'll get into that
huh squidward is on heroin
he's always down and yells at spongebob
for being hyped up
and energetic now mr krabs
that boy is hitting the slopes
doing some coke mr grabs on coke he's
always really uppity
and he's concerned about money coke is
expensive
that makes sense
um you know facts
those are bad facts like i can kind of
see it um
unfortunately don't want to
but patrick's for sure
mr krabs absolutely i think
i think squidward
i don't know about heroin i wouldn't say
heroin
i think he's on like i'm trying to think
what's like some
maybe like no now it makes me wonder
what plankton was on
i think that's just who he is i think
he's just
he's thinking i don't do drugs we don't
do drugs
i don't really know but he's married to
a computer
maybe he's just a i don't
he's on my strange addiction that's what
plankton would be on
my strange addiction you know when
people marry
machines last time we watched this
rollercoaster he doesn't need to have
drugs in him he's just
loves a machine my strange addiction
yeah
it's like the her version of you know
it's basically joaquin joaquin phoenix
as a plankton what the [ __ ] are we
talking about
are we what's are we on something i
don't even know we're high on life
and red bull what's up with that all
right let's move on from this i'm sorry
that was a bad theory
i'll get back no no i liked it i liked
it okay we'll do better
though so now we're just going to jump
into our last
and final segment unsolicited
advice and you know how it is christine
told you in the beginning how to submit
your questions
i can remind you one more time apple
podcast put the five star and put your
questions and we will
absolutely answer them if they're nice
and it's five stars
so this one is from i don't know how to
pronounce that
but it says hey girls i love the podcast
it's fate okay
thank you it's hey girls i love the
podcast
my name is oh her name is faith oh i
love that name oh
hi bae hi faith so my name is faith and
i'm currently a freshman in college
congrats i am wondering if you guys have
any tips for eating healthy while on a
meal plan
as well as maneuvering time management
love you both
we love you too thank you for listening
to the podcast and writing in correctly
you are true listener for actually
paying attention
so let's start with the first part of
the question so freshman in college
and eating healthy while on a meal plan
i feel like that's kind of hard because
there's always that
you know once you sort of move away from
home and there's
just endless options of good food on a
college campus it's very easy to get
into
plan is something yeah i would meet a
meal plan especially when i was in
college is you can have certain
you can only go to certain places and
there's like if you get like a gold
membership you get more it's there's a
lot of things like you use your card as
a money
thing so you have like credit on it but
i'll tell you this faith i
did not know how to eat healthy
when i was a freshman in college and i'm
a very healthy person i've always been
but when i got into college i think i
was just so chaotic in every other
area of my life that i didn't even focus
on my health and
honestly if my health is not at its peak
my mind is not at
speak and then my body's not at its peak
and
i definitely like gained a lot of
unhealthy weight
um and it's fine i mean it's not a big
deal
everyone goes through it but i do think
it's really important to start early
so you get a good routine and a good
habit and so what i
did when i was a freshman when i was a
sophomore basically in college
was i tried to go for the foods that i
knew
were healthy you can look at a table and
you go okay if i choose the pizza
look i'm also saying this if you want a
pizza
if you want a hamburger i just want to
practice this go at it who cares
honestly who cares that's all i ate
freshman year was pizza
and um cinnamon toast crunch literally
every day that's what he lived
he lived above a five guys burger i
lived above five guys burgers so you
know
that those fries were in my place every
step of the way
and a taco bell and the mcdonald's so
it was great but um i was literally in
heaven but i would just say
you know the things that are good for
your body you know the things that are
going to really sustain it so
if you want you need some carbs if you
need something for breakfast like that
get an oatmeal with a ton of berries and
some healthy fats if you're
having lunch and you are really hungry
get
a sandwich and put like really good
greens on it but it's a
good protein on it um don't put too much
sauces and stuff like that
and then at dinner i always like to do
this so i don't
kind of go off if i have i'll always
have a late night snack if i'm hungry
but
i like to do a certain time frame of
what i'm going to eat i'm going to eat
at 8 a.m
before my class meet at 12 o'clock in
the middle of class yeah
eat at six or whenever i end at at that
start time and then from now on out
unless i am hungry
i'll just do my work and then go to bed
it's also easier to
eat healthy foods and snacks especially
if you want a snack because you're
living in a dorm
and you have your fridge so what you put
in there is what you're gonna
eat obviously so if you only put in junk
food and you're hungry and you're like
oh shoot i just want a quick bite like
try to put carrots and hummus like what
do we eat all the time we eat carrots
hummus
um do
it's so good um we have for breakfast we
have oatmeal every morning we have a
smoothie we have yogurt with a little
granola and berries like yeah
there's so many things you can do with
it but then on the weekends
those are our fun days cheat day go hard
go out you earned it for eating healthy
during the week so just
i feel like eating management with your
eating is also the same thing with like
school time management it's all about
giving yourself a little bit of leeway
so not being so strict
all the time so don't be so strict that
oh my god i need to
have count calories and only have a
little bit of salad and only eat carrots
like
no no no no i'll tell you right now i
used a calorie count and i said this on
the podcast before i used to be very
very very
analytical about what i was eating and
my body looks so much better
not doing that when i'm just relaxed
right when you're relaxing
when sofia and i when sophia and i
started to do intuitive eating
so eating when we were hungry and not
eating when
it was appropriate lunch time that's
when we really
felt our body change for the better and
then
the second part of your question was
maneuvering time management
the best way i like to do it is because
sometimes i'll look at all of the work i
have to do either for the day or for the
week
and studying for a test and it honestly
overwhelms me
my brain starts going crazy just
thinking about all of the [ __ ] that i
have to do
so i will put my phone away look at the
time i'll say it's three o'clock
from three to four no electronics
obviously if you need to use your
computer you can
and just focus on that and you can get
so much more work done when you're just
like not procrastinating and you're in
your own
zone your element but yeah definitely
put the phone away and then also give
yourself 30 minutes
that's how i like to do it so like i'll
work hard for an hour 30 minutes on
tick tock on my phone on instagram and
then i'll do another 45
and i literally you know giving yourself
um
i call it a brain break really helps at
least me
because i can't study for six hours i
will not ingest
anything i also think a really good way
to also stop
like have some good time management is
book up like block some hours where
you're like i'm gonna go sit in front of
this cafe and work
like getting also out of your own
environment which where you sleep where
you eat all that stuff
it can get a little bit you get
distracted so
go i finally i always use my calendar on
my phone or i had
i used in college i used to have a
written one like a paper
planner and really write it out and then
follow those and i think when you have
something that is written down as a
checklist
and you see what you have to do
throughout the day you will do it
so faith i hope we helped you i know we
just gave you a lot
but um do with what you may and
let us know and thank you for watching
yeah thank you so much
and thank you guys for listening to
today's episode we
had such a fun time we're sorry it's a
day late
but like the fee and i are doing this on
our own now
we're running this podcast independently
so we're trying to figure out how to do
it
a hundred percent alone so
bear with us we'll figure it out and
we'll get much better thank you guys for
joining us and we will see you next
tuesday
bye bye